well let's speak now to the leader of
the house of commons andrea ledson ms
ledson
a very good morning to you um a busy day
ahead for you
uh one suspect can we just have
confirmed um
the way in which that full legal advice
uh will be released
well we will publish it this morning the
plan is at 11
30. why was the government
so reticent to publish in fool at the
advice that members of cabinet like
yourself had seen
on a point of principle so there are
conflicting
constitutional issues here of course
uh the house of commons has the right
through the humble address to require
papers
and having passed its vote yesterday we
will comply with that
but there's a really important
constitutional principle whereby
law officers give confidential frank
advice to government ministers and its
very existence
is not normally published let alone the
advice itself
and the reason that's so important is
because now
following the vote yesterday as i say we
will comply with it
the problem in future will be that law
officers will think twice
about the type of advice that they give
to government and government will have
to think very carefully about what sort
of advice they ask for
for fear that the house of commons might
again in future
require it to be fully disclosed so
there are two very important principles
here
one which is the preeminence of the
house of commons and the other which is
the importance of confidential and
impartial advice
and those two things were in clash
yesterday and actually i do think that
parliamentarians who
want to be in government in the future
will live to regret the decision they
they took last night well indeed but on
reflection was this strategically the
best day to have that particular battle
could you not have let it slide i mean
we have not had a government held in
contempt in this way
ever before now that might be framed in
arcane parliamentary language
but on a day full of embarrassments for
the prime minister that was a pretty big
one
well again you know this this was not of
the government's timing
um the attorney general came to the
house on monday
for a two and a half hour statement
where he answered
every single question from all members
and also published a 48-page document
setting out all of the legal
implications of the withdrawal agreement
and the political declaration
so the house of commons was in
absolutely no doubt whatsoever
about the attorney general's legal
advice so the issue yesterday the
decision of opposition parties
to hold to to to hold this vote on
contempt
was really one that they were determined
to see the confidential advice and i
argued very hard that this was a very
difficult breach
that the house had seen all of the legal
advice and that this should be a step
that they shouldn't take but of course
with the um state that that the house of
commons is in with that
it really went on to party political
lines i'm afraid and i'm i
deeply regret that i i wonder if we
might just move on to to the amendment
put forward and agreed by the house put
forward by uh dominic grave of course
your former colleague and cabinet
what's your understanding of the effect
that that has
we heard from dominic rabb a few minutes
ago suggesting look it's not binding it
can be ignored
in fact let's just have a listen to what
mr rabb said a few minutes ago
what is clear is that um the vote
yesterday
will not affect the the ultimate outcome
because votes in parliament on motions
are not legally binding so if no no
absolutely absolutely
yeah but politically i mean understand
the legal the legal argument but
politically are you saying
that that could be ignored by the
government look to to reverse the course
of brexit will require
legislation or lack of will
in number 10 downing street and i
believe this prime minister
is true to her word that she's going to
deliver brexit she always said no deal
was better than a bad deal and i think
if parliament turns this deal down we
shouldn't flounce off we should go back
and make a reasonable best
final offer to brussels but ultimately
we do need to be willing to walk away
and that's the only way in any
negotiation
you get sensible terms you're arguing
you're arguing that you're ignoring the
will of the house of commons that didn't
work out very well for you yesterday did
it
well what i'm doing is setting the clear
constitutional position which is
motions of parliament a politically uh
have weight for sure but they don't
legally
bind the government and what matters
right now both domestically
but also in brussels is political
resolve and will
so let's just be clear dominic grieve's
amendment doesn't matter
it didn't matter i said it didn't have
legally binding force and therefore
it cannot alone stop brexit or reverse
the outcome and the outcome is that
unless something changes
matters we will leave the eu at the end
of march with a deal or without a deal
i would like us to get a deal but we're
going to have to be much tougher with
brussels much
firmer and more resolute if we're going
to get them to take us more seriously
misled some you managed to hear in full
there that the the views of dominic rams
a very straightforward question will the
government honor that amendment
well dominic grieve's amendment which i
fully understand gives the house
a further opportunity to give its views
on an amendable vote basis
in the event that this deal doesn't go
through
and that's perfectly fine i understand
why he wants to do that
but dominic raab's assessment is correct
that in order for the
um for the march 29th
um leaving the eu to change
there needs to be legislation so if it's
not the prime minister's deal
through the withdrawal agreement or
another deal then the default position
will be
no deal next march the 29th
but do you not want to have i mean one
of the common complaints that has been
made by both sides of the house by
people on both sides of the house is
that they haven't had sufficient input
that there hasn't been consensus
gathered
surely mr grieve's amendment at least
suggests
if it was honored by the government it
would suggest that you are open
to new ideas open to fresh approaches
because as things stand the deal that
theresa may says is the only one on the
table is not going to pass the house on
tuesday
well you know i i really hope that
colleagues will listen very carefully
over the next few days of debate there
have been an awful lot of
misunderstandings about what's in the
withdrawal agreement and in the
political declaration
and the truth of it is that there isn't
a majority for a particular solution in
parliament
and the prime minister has been clear
she has negotiated
as hard as she believes is feasible is
realistic
with the european union it's been a very
tough negotiation
i know for many of my brexit colleagues
and of course for me too
the issue of the backstop is a very
concerning one
and that is a matter of political risk
will we end up in it
and i think what what should be clear
that misled some you you have concerns
about the backstop but as things stand
you agree with the deal
yes i i'm not happy about the backstop
but what i was going to say is
it is a matter of political risk the eu
also
very much do not want the backstop what
it does is it gives the uk
access to eu markets without free
movement
without making any contributions to
their budget without the common
fisheries policy and without the common
agricultural policy
so eu 27
okay i'm sorry to interrupt again i'm
being so so horribly on gallant but
it does rather sound to me that you
would prefer if the prime minister lost
on tuesday went to brussels and
renegotiated the deal
i'm i'm not saying that at all what i'm
asking is for colleagues to listen very
carefully
to the proposals over the next few days
in the run-up to the meaningful vote
to be absolutely clear what is being
talked about in this deal
for me the reason why i can live with
this deal and support this deal
is because it's the only deal on the
table and it's my political assessment
that it's unlikely that we would find
ourselves in that backstop
but just once again in terms of there
being further input
um from the body politic from the back
benches on that deal
under mr grieve's amendment just very
straightforwardly
will the government honor that
opportunity for mps to do so
of course the government will honor the
opportunity for mps to express a vote
that was uh the express will of the
house yesterday
and we will of course honor it but just
to put this in perspective you know
during the withdrawal act
we had 1500 hours of debate uh
sorry 1500 amendments proposed and
nearly 300
hours of debate on that withdrawal act
it was one of the most um
contributed to ever in the house of
lords
more speakers to it than on any bill
ever before
you know just in the last couple of
weeks the prime minister has spoken
at the dispatch box on the subject of
her deal for more than 12 hours taking
questions from across the
house of commons so there has been a
huge amount of input we now have um
the second day today of five days with
eight hours each day protected time
of discussion on the meaningful vote and
then culminating in votes next tuesday
so all colleagues will have had the
opportunity to air their views to
air their concerns to put forward their
alternative proposals
but just to be clear there isn't a
majority in the house for one particular
solution over another
and the default position if we cannot
agree a deal is that we leave the eu
next march without a deal um
do you honestly never sit at home at
night in front of the fire and say to
yourself do you know what this could
have all been different
if only they'd made me leader of the
conservative party well i very rarely
get the chance to sit at home in front
of the fire
maybe that's the answer no i think the
prime minister has shown such incredible
determination and tenacity there is
no doubt that she has really worked in
the national interest to try and get
this deal through
to try and balance the interests of the
big majority 17.4 million people the
biggest democratic exercise ever
who voted to leave the eu whilst at the
same time protecting our economy
protecting jobs
and protecting the views of those on the
remain side of the argument
who want to continue to have a very
close relationship with the eu
and i think what she's offering is the
best of both worlds freedom to be
a global free trading nation whilst at
the same time keeping a very special and
deep relationship with our eu friends
and neighbors